no time to die daniel craig's final
outing as james bond ties up a lot of
loose ends from his tenure on screen as
a renowned super spy when the dust
settles the day has been saved and this
era of bond has drawn to a close we
still have some unanswered questions
no time to die is a whopping 2 hours and
45 minutes long with a 30 minute opening
sequence the most stirring part of this
epic opening set piece comes when bond
at the behest of madeleine swann visits
the final resting place of west lind the
love interest who betrayed him in casino
royale madeleine wants to start a new
life with james and that requires
closing the chapters behind them for
madeleine that means telling james or
the secret she's never shared but for
james that means forgiving a dead woman
he still loves when he gets to her grave
it's been booby-trapped and explodes in
his face setting his quest in motion and
severing his trust with madeline who he
now believes must be vesper 2.0 having
lured him into this mess later in the
film blofeld confesses to bond that as
inspector he was the author of this
particular pain point knowing bond would
eventually visit her tomb and that's all
he had to do was bide his time what's
not explicitly spelled out is just how
long he had been planning this at that
point in the film blofeld has been in
prison for half a decade so did he have
his long distance henchmen rig up the
cemetery with explosives even before he
wound up incarcerated or were his men on
the outside just keeping tabs on bond
and the hopes and emotional ultimatum in
his relationship would lead to him being
at the right place at the wrong time
the film's opening flashback reveals a
fuller portrait of a plot point
originally revealed inspector that
madeleine's mother was killed by one of
her father mr white's enemies while she
was a child hiding upstairs here we see
that the enemy was new bond villain
lucifer saffin played by rami malik we
find out safin himself had his own
family brutally slaughtered by white so
his revenge was inevitable but when
madeleine as a child fights back against
his attack and he chases her to the
point she collapses under a frozen lake
safin chooses to rescue her in present
day after the five year time jump safin
reappears in madeleine's life and makes
her an unwitting pawn in his master plan
making it clear he's been obsessed with
her since that fateful day
you don't know what this is
but the film was built around the
premise that the full details of their
connection will prove devastating to
james in a way they do because madeline
and james have lost years of their lives
not even speaking because the plot's
circumstances convinced him she wasn't
to be trusted which couldn't be further
from the truth we just never find out
more about safin and madeline's
connection he must have taken her to
safety after retrieving her from under
the ice but did he help raise her for a
time he claims to have kept a close
watch on her over the years but was she
ever aware was there more to this shared
history or was it all just a misdirect
after appearing in both casino royale
and quantum of solace as franchise star
wars felix leiter bond's american bestie
played by jeffrey wright was nowhere to
be seen in the ensuing two sequels he
returns here as a catalyst for much of
the film's plot and when he does lighter
and bond seem even closer and chummier
than they did when he was still a brand
new double o this mission the two men
embark on together proves to be their
last as lighter dies in front of bond
drowning and suffering from gunshot
wounds from fellow spook logan ash who
betrayed them both it proves to be one
of the film's most affecting moments
largely because of the palpable
chemistry between craig and wright bond
being an international agent is presumed
he and leiter worked on many many unseen
missions in between his last appearance
and this film but we still wonder what
he was up to as a rogue former mi6 agent
rather murk in skyfall and the spectre
became such a powerful force for
terrorism
in a key moment in the film safin uses a
kidnapped mi6 scientist to alter a
weaponized disease blofeld was planning
to use to kill bond making it backfire
and kill every living member of spectre
this happens at a ball thrown for the
evil organization with blofeld in prison
attending via the connection from his
bionic eye to a mirrored one out in the
real world when bond has to explain to
him that blofeld has been orchestrating
spectre activities from behind bars
using his bionic eye em explains that no
one sees or speaks to blofeld all day
outside of his therapist madeline but
how did mi6 not notice this man had a
cybernetic science fiction eyeball for
the last five years
the film's primary mcguffin is project
heracles a bioweapon designed to only
affect genetically marked targets mi6
was developing it as an off the books
program that would make missions simpler
and risk fewer field agents lives
somehow m is surprised when it's stolen
by spectre then saturn's upstart
operation and repurposed as a weapon of
mass destruction in the film's climax
saffin's island existing in a nebulous
ungoverned space between russia and
japan must be destroyed to stop project
heracles from being deployed globally
he's going to kill millions m struggles
to navigate the quagmire strategically
because england can't be seen as
instigating an international incident
especially when the impetus behind it
would reveal gross negligence on their
parts so when the dust cleared how did
em avoid catastrophic geopolitical
blowback after destroying the island
with missiles as the remaining cast
eulogizes the fallen it certainly
appears em still has his job so he must
have executed some true diplomatic
finesse to keep his head
when no time to die and its lengthy
credits finally crawl to a close the
film's closing message is that james
bond will return but not only is daniel
craig not returning for another film his
iteration of james bond meets an
untimely end in a tragic scene of
self-sacrifice in the movie's final act
we know how this goes new bond actor
usually means new bond continuity but
we're in uncharted territory now that we
have a canonical bond film that shows
the hero dying at the end so with the
shauna lynch's nomi most likely
reclaiming her official designation as
double 07 after temporarily
relinquishing it to bond on his last
mission will she return in another film
just because the next bond film will
probably start from scratch doesn't mean
this particular world can't continue in
a spin-off sequel especially given the
warm reception to lynch's performance
and phoebe wore the bridge's exceptional
writing folks have been clamoring for a
female bond or a black bond in recent
years but perhaps now that lynch has
done such a fine job with nomi a black
female 07 why not give her a solo film
devoted to fleshing her out further
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
no time to die are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you